hey everyone this is kevin from the
chess website comm and today we're going
to be going over the Bogle Indian
offense which starts out with pawn to d4
Knight f6 pawn c4 pawn East six and then
Knight to f3 more common would be Knight
to c3 but this gets into the
nimzo-indian defense so sometimes as
White's maybe looking to avoid that line
and so you play Knight to f3 or you run
into this if you're playing black and
now Black's gonna play Bishop to b4
probably more common is the Queen's
Indian defense with pawn to b6 there's
another video on the Queen's Indian
defense if you want to watch that but in
this video we're gonna be looking at the
BOGO Indian defense and that is the
bishop coming here to b4 there's really
three main lines that you're gonna see
here because there's just not too many
options that white has usually not gonna
see this Knights get in coming down here
to d2
usually the options are gonna be one
Knight to c3 this is really just the
Kasparov variation in the nimzo-indian
defense because this plays just like
that there is another video I have on
the nimzo-indian defense where we go
over this specific variation so if
you're curious you can definitely watch
that video but the other two main lines
that we're gonna be looking at one is
Bishop - D - you are under check here so
what you want to stop that and there is
the knight coming here to d2 now both
have their advantages we're gonna look
at all the different variations from
those I'll give my recommendations on
how you should approach each of those
some of the key moves to look at the
main line is for white to play Bishop to
d2 this immediately puts pressure on the
bishop on before and says ok you're
gonna have to do something either
retreats exchange material do something
but I'm threatening that right away now
it's not super common but black may
decide to go ahead and take the bishop
here on a d2 and the reason it's not
that common is if you're gonna move one
of your minor pieces a couple moves in
the beginning of the game you want to
have some sort of compensation white can
immediately just take with the Queen
here let's say black castles on the
inside Knight to c3 getting ready to
push forward with pawn to e4 black
really doesn't have much in terms of
compensation for moving the minor piece
a few times in the early game state
instead White has a pretty solid board
state especially in the center once they
can play that pawn to e4 that's one of
the main reasons you play Knight to c3
is because you're looking to play pawn
to e4 and control the entire center of
the board with your pawn so not
something you'll generally see from
black just giving up that bishop instead
you may see Queen to e7 now this has
yeah I don't want to move my bishop a
couple places just to give it up but if
you want to move your bishop a couple
squares and then I will exchange so
bishop takes and the Queen could just
capture back here now black has that
upper hand as far as a move perspective
and so now why it's gonna have to either
defend with the Knights or exchange off
Queens it's gonna do something but black
has a more active position so this is
one option to play the Queen here to e7
now White's not going to take the bishop
that is not the recommended move but
really if blacks not looking to take the
bishop I recommend playing Knight to c3
this board say it's gonna play very
different than the nimzo-indian defense
so I think it's safe to go ahead and
play Knight to c3 you do want to have
the knight involved into the action so
that you can be looking to play pawn to
e4 at some point if we see this and now
the bishop takes the bishop can freely
recapture I think this is going to be a
completely fine spot for for whites
maybe Knight to c3 and then pawn to b6
getting ready to bring the bishop here
now you can play pawn to e3 if you want
to solidify this pawn chain here maybe
Bishop to b7 Bishop to d3 this stops
some of the threats of the knight coming
to e4 which black may want to do the
knight here on F 3 is still being
protected by the Queen here on d1 can
now castle on the King side so White has
a lot of different options here
with the solid the solid pawn structure
in the center of the board so that's how
I would continue there and if they say
hey I'm not even looking to do you know
an aggressive move on the queenside if
they just want to castle on the kingside
yeah you may just want to play pawn to
e3 here as well
solidify the pawn chain now you can get
the light square bishop out castle on
the King side of the board so that's
what I would play if you see this Queen
here to e7 the next variation is pretty
ambitious it's Poinsett a5 and while I
don't play the big money in defense all
too often as black this is one of my
favorite lines that black can go down
because it really starts to put a lot of
pressure on the Queen side of the board
so this defends this Bishop here does
not get the Queen involvement to the
game
just yet very similar as we saw when the
Queen came to e7 I would just recommend
white playing Knight here to c3
completely fine says hey yeah if you're
not gonna do anything with your bishop
here I'm not gonna worry about here I'm
definitely not gonna use one of my moves
to come over here and take here on
before because then you're gonna have a
pretty annoying pawn here on b4 if you
capture you know after the bishop takes
the pawn recaptures this opens up the
door for the rook have a semi-open file
to really attack that's not what white
wants to do if you kind of analyze how
you exchange pieces that's not gonna be
good so Knight to c3 is going to be the
recommended line now if we come back and
say instead of the pawn to a5 another
option is pawn to c5 now this is the one
spot where I recommend yes they haven't
taken the bishop on d2 but I wouldn't
play Knight to c3 just because I think
there's a much better move and that is
just to simply take here on b4 and yes
they're going to recapture if they don't
it'd be just a terrible move here but
then you could play pawn to a3 you want
to get rid of this pawn it's pretty
annoying because you really want to be
playing Knight to c3 and it does stop it
from happening but now black really has
to to figure out what they want to do if
they want to take
with their pawn that's fine you can
recapture with the rook here has Anna
Semyon file for the rook to attack here
now the knight can freely come to c3
pretty good setup that white has here if
he doesn't move anywhere if he and the
instead plays Knight to c6 okay go ahead
and take that pawn if the knight takes
on b4 that's fine
play pawn to e3 solidifying the pawn
chain LightSquared bishop is defending
the pawn here on C before you can get it
ready to castle on the King side so
White has a lot of options if that's how
black wants to continue the other option
for black is just to retreat back here
to e7 pretty safe place for black to be
this does allow white to really develop
a lot of their pieces so Knight to c3
getting ready to play pawn to e4 wants
to can always just play the safer pawn
to e3 solidify the pawn chain but now
black is gonna be looking to castle on
the King side of the board and really
just see how white wants to continue but
no pieces have really been committed so
far for black so that's how you're gonna
play if you see some of the more common
variations from black after Bishop to d2
now if you decide you don't really like
the bishop coming here to be to the
other option would be to play Knight to
d2 it's more of a passive opening just
because you're not forcing the bishop
here on b4 to move at least on this move
right now so black has a lot of
different options as far as how they
could continue maybe pawn to b6 at this
point yes you can now play pawn to a3 if
they want to exchange I think that's a
win for white here you know now White
has the bishop pair black does not gonna
be looking to open up the board meaning
getting rid of these pawns on the stern
of the board so the bishop pair can
reign supreme here if instead after pawn
to a3 the bishop comes back to e7
well now pawn to e4 and this is a key
difference that because the knight is
here on D - yes it is blocking the dark
square bishop but it is now defending
the square here on
before remember that one of the reasons
you bring the Knight to c3 is we can
defend the square here on e4 so once
it's here on d2 if it's left alone it's
now going to also defend at this square
here on e4 so from here if you were to
see pawn to d6 you could a lot of
different variations that black could
play Queen deceits who I recommend this
just adds another layer of protection
both the pawns here on a c4 and E for
now protected by the Queen now you can
get your Bishop involvement of the game
castle on the King side why it's gonna
do very well controlling the center of
the board and having all of their minor
pieces very active the only thing you
have to keep in mind if you are gonna
play this is the dark square Bishop many
times can be left alone and not really
doing much because it is blocked off by
the dark squared bishop here so that's
something that blacks gonna be looking
to attack as well so those are some of
the main lines that you'll see in the
BOGO Indiana fence some of the others
you can get from different videos the
names of any defense from the Kasparov
variation but that is an introduction to
the book lending in defense hope you
enjoyed let me know what you guys think
of this video if there's other openings
you want me to cover feel free to let me
know you can always email me and I will
definitely respond try to make as many
videos as you guys want but thanks again
for watching I'll see you guys in the
next video